bonjour commandement
non non non c'est maintenant les siens
je m'occupais a calculé le centre de la
grand-place
parce que moi dit que la grand place 7e
centre de la belgique
alors je calcule comme ça aussi que
c'est au centre de la belgique
voilà nom d une chance mais je vous
reconnais vous nom de zhu pets allez on
n'en fait pas vous êtes le mieux si oui
c'est ça vous êtes le monsieur qui fait
présentateur de la télévision en france
ces saints noms des sources
on ne fait pas à moi vous allez tomber
demain c'est un [ __ ] j'avais sous
quinze jours zeller mc des chavannes
nous devons aussi raconté sa lettre à m
c'est celle que j'aime bien mon pays
garde toi tu es bettman a résulté
bettman pour moi c'est non mais qu'est
ce que tu fais comme mission alors moi
j'ai fait plein de choses à plat
mais aujourd'hui justement vous êtes là
vous êtes là pour faire touristes aux
est l'heure pour le cinéma pour faire
touristes parce que si vous voulez un
mois je pris peu à peu vous promener ici
dans bruxelles
et vous savez même pas quoi monsieur
quand vous êtes même assez connu et
c'est quand même dangereux pour vous un
jeu peut même être pour vous garde du
corps
ah bon bondy garton 10 matchs en fait
bonne garde et quand on parle de corent
leur amour du cholestérol et syriens
tués jazz comme un tu prends pour faire
gardes du corps quand même comme c'est
quand même quelqu'un d'autre que nous
voulons fabriquer une pizza une bonne
petite bière bien moussante ouais ça
vous massa mais quand on parle de
tourisme
vous connaissez le manneken pis wi fi
nintendo
parce que sinon je vais vous serez aussi
on connaît les parce que vous savez même
pas quoi
j'ai appris un bondir indien que dans le
bassin d'orage du manneken pis ils
poussent des écrevisses rendez compte
alors j'ai ici mon petit matériel et on
va aller voir les déchets ok c'est pour
moi c'est un petit pipi les dix mois
bettman
il suffit comme mission est ce que tu te
ramasses des crottes de chiens ah oui ça
ça mérite autant l'essentiel plus cher
1,33 pour un plus qui sait les primes de
risque et à suivre et alors
reste que j'ai fait beaucoup elles ont
géré surveiller les machines dans les
labos matic à la scène tourne bien c'est
faux bien me tournait l'an de grâce à ce
que j'ai pu faire aussi c'est raconter
la rechute des feuilletons ratez pas ça
c'est difficile aussi parce que parfois
ça tombe à l'heure de mars est alors
j'ai pensé un petit peu bouchés ou alors
je vais décrocher les cherche un minou
dans la corniche et m et 1 md chasse on
nettoie ah oui
le problème c'est qu'après ses matelots
celui des centres non les jo c'est pas
de tout repos à la vie de super héros
l'invité super héros anti otan canada
c'est une terre grâce non 9 classes
savent et le disent et qu'est ce qui se
passe là quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe non
[Musique]
on peut se donner aux siens au psg vous
dire
suivez l'avancée de sa porte d'honneur
quand on touche ici mais alors vous
voyez en fait un bras de fer vers aveux
et alors on voit quelle activité qui ne
sont pas restés au soir ils ont été des
champs sont difficiles ici un petit
chien aussi vous aurez noté chien en
droit c'est celui là il était grand
temps
[Musique]
et bien sûr madame
voilà tu désolé on en fait kam ap mobile
qui tombait en panne juste là bas sinon
arrêté en voiture et hommage et le
remercier
j'ai vu mais aussi des jo il était
bourdy le métro à supporter pas je suis
tellement le coffre fort que parfois
l'on supporte n'aime pas mes lunettes
alors je dis bien la grèce appelé
map et robin
il y avait le jouer une place qui était
coincé dans les essuie-glaces et ça
c'est encore un coup de boue d'inaction
[Musique]
c
merci bettman aller
[Musique]
m
on marche un petit peu je vous expliquez
vous les écrevisses j'ai trouvé un truc
pour les péchés regarder ma canne à
pêche un fils et une pince à linge
alors je vais jeter la pince à linge
dans l'eau exit police elles vont venir
elles vont du monde et jo ça doit être
un cousin éloigné on va aller me serrer
la pince
ils vont s'imposer et à ce moment-là
grave une petite puce magique le plat
c'est génial vous voyez aussi que si
patty méchant j'ai mis un petit peu être
caoutchouc pour avoir fait trop mal
enfin on voudrait de vache pour réduire
les bouffées
dans son enceinte magnifique est un méta
chanson le zizi de pierre perret le
manneken pis elle saisit le pcn remonte
et les photographes vif des milliers de
fois par jour
on a déjà prélevé par des chinois des
russes et américains dans le monde
entier on le connaît c'est moi
je serai pas déçu parce qu'on s'attend
souvent voir grand ouais léopard - voilà
on est tout petit mais patrick qu'est ce
qui est petit le zizi du malawi
voilà aux urgences comme en ce moment
j'ai flashé ici pourquoi y aller
vas-y batman
[Musique]
[Rires]
il ya des cichlidés hollande
c'était il ya des siècles quand
bruxelles était soudain évasion espagnol
y avait des espèces de terroriste
puisque thierry pocquet dévaler un
espèce de terroriste qui aurait mis une
bombe en dessous de l'hôtel de ville de
bruxelles et alors ce jour là je demande
un petit gamin à moins de quelques
musiciens étaient sortis en cachette
dans la maison et quand il avait la
bombe la veille à ce qu'il a fait il a
pissé dessus voilà il a fait son petit
pipi sous la mèche ces dates de sa voix
là et alors quand les parents qui succès
les gosses est arrivé ils ont dit la
maquette pis et voilà voilà voilà pour
l'instant
voila voila je sens
ainsi dans ce taxi oulala je sens je
sens mon mon téléphone vibrant qui
résonne dans mes hanches ou sa dette
rien appels prioritaires sa fille comme
les nerfs venir ici au monde
elle est mon écouteurs quoi
montage ans j'arrive de suite
mademoiselle ces vies qui vendent ils
paieraient qui est un vieux sortir qu'il
a séquestrée téléphonique de l'avenue du
départ but shakur tout de suite ça c'est
de nouveau un coup de bonnac cette
chance j'ai 28 ans et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu